Hello there,
Mr Ruben [inaudible].
All right,
Jp January one we got anything good for the people?
Well,
I don't know how good it is.
Um,
I guess we're going to find out how good it is.
I,
it's not something I'm thrilled about by any stretch of the imagination.
So you and I have been talking for a couple of weeks now ever since this scandal
around Carl Benjamin or Sargon of the cod broken.
We decided,
well a while back that we were going to while do a variety of things,
right?
We were going to announce our departure from Patrion,
which is what we're doing in this video.
I'm going to leave Patriot on January 15th
I also am going to leave Patrion on January 15th which by the way,
we should just be clear.
This is not something that we wanted to do.
We were both perfectly happy on Patriot and Patriot on,
at least for me,
it's been the backbone of my show.
I mean that's somewhere between 60 and 70% of our funding is through Patrion.
So this is not something we wanted to do.
I know we're going to talk about a whole bunch of things in this reporting.
Uh,
but that New York Times article that came out,
the implication was,
oh,
we're doing this for money.
It's like we're taking a major hit right now and opening ourselves up to all
sorts of risks.
So I'm going ahead and doing that because I believe we can do something better.
We've got to figure out exactly what that is and that's what we're working on.
So we can say two things.
I mean,
I,
I'd also like to thank the patron people for what they did in the past because
they provided me with a tremendous amount of,
or the ability,
the opportunity to generate a tremendous amount of financial support at a time.
I really needed it.
And so I'm not happy in the least with what has happened.
I have thought about it a lot and believe that given patrons proclivity to
sensor and the reasons that they're doing it,
especially as I've looked more and more deeply into the reasons,
um,
particularly with regards to my discovery of the website changed the terms,
I've become increasingly convinced that it's unethical to continue my
association with the company.
And I also agree,
Jack Conti said in that New York Times article trying to justify,
say Sam Harris's departure and are threatened departure,
that it was motivated primarily by financial gain and like,
look,
I've got nothing against financial gain.
You know,
I've said that from the beginning.
I,
and if,
if things that I'm doing generate an honest amount of money that I can put two
reasonable use than so much the better,
but mmm [inaudible] this is a major financial blow.
I'm using the patron money for a variety of reasons.
Most particularly to support this educational endeavor that I've talked to
people about.
Right.
Our attempt to build an online education system.
And so like it's a major hit.
Yeah.
And of course,
you know,
just to be clear,
it's like when,
when we're doing my show,
I mean I don't have to tell about youtube demonetization,
but for example in my show a week or two ago with your mom too,
ed was demonetized by the algorithm then demonetized further after manual review
by a human,
so it's patriot,
it's the,
it's the supporters,
the individual people that allow us to go ahead and do more of these
controversial so to speak episodes.
So yeah,
just nothing that we're doing right now is against the people that have
supported us or our patrons or anything like that.
This is,
this is about making a stand against this ever moving encroachments on free
speech on free expression and the rest of it,
and it's like this is one that we just feel is the right one to make the move
on.
And the reason that we jointly decided on January 15th while there was a couple
of reasons,
the first wisdom,
we thought that we might have something approximating an alternative potentially
available for preliminary launch at that date.
Although we've decided to delay that because the user interface needs work
because that's the other thing,
right?
Is that their needs perhaps to be a replacement for patron,
if that's a possibility,
like it's not obvious to me that corporations can run platforms for untrammeled
communication successfully on the net in today's climate and that food,
anything I might design,
well let's not,
let's not gloss over that.
I mean it might be possible that the patrion method is not what's needed exactly
for the future of the Internet.
I mean this is what we're trying to figure out right now,
which is why we've got every engineer,
I mean people from Google and Facebook and Yahoo and everybody reaching out to
us because it's like everyone's trying to solve this problem and it's still,
I mean one of the things we've been talking about now for the last,
well it's really for the last year,
but in intensely in the last month is what actually is the problem itself
because until we really figure out what the problem is.
Well,
I think,
I think the problem is
how to regulate an incredibly diverse range of opinions.
If such regulation needs to be instantiated,
we could take a limit case,
for example,
the desire of companies like Facebook,
not to have their platforms used for recruitment for Isis.
It's hard to make a case that that's not a reasonable restriction.
Right.
But then,
but then the next issue is
I think you could make an exception there because maybe you consider that a war
time exception or something like that.
But then the fundamental problem to me seems to be,
and I'll return again to that change the terms website that a whole variety of
companies and organizations spearheaded in not least by the southern poverty law
center,
that hateful organization
that has decided that they're going to uh,
compel encourage.
Uh,
what
if fame,
perhaps companies that don't band together to what they see as hate speech.
Yeah.
And this is where,
well,
this is where the moving line is the key part of this,
because you can always find the free,
the most fringe cases.
You can always find isis on one side and you know,
the most fringe KKK,
white supremacist group or whatever you want to call it on the other side.
But let's not forget southern poverty law center.
They've written things about you.
They've read things about me.
I on Hirsi Ali and marginalize and Sam Harris and I and a litany of Majid sued
them to,
to actually want.
So there,
there is a push back,
but this is just another level of the stand.
It's like they cannot be trusted to be on the boards of any of these
organizations that are deciding what terms of service they are should have
access.
It's really who should have access to the Internet.
It's just,
it's worse than that,
Dave,
because when they start to pressure the credit card companies,
and I would consider this a warning to everyone who's listening.
It's like,
okay,
let's see,
let's think this through.
So the New York Times last week wrote an article about the credit cards.
Complicity in loaning money to that terrible tiny minority of people who engaged
in mass shootings,
right?
Stating that it was the responsibility of the credit card companies to monitor
and potentially prevent that activities.
Like,
okay,
so what's the,
what's the idea here?
The idea is that the companies to whom we have in trusted our monetary system in
large parts,
that would be the credit card companies now get to review our spending patterns
to determine if what we purchase is in accordance with that,
with what they regard as morally acceptable.
Okay.
And,
and,
and we think that's a good idea that that's where we're headed.
And Mastercard and visa and paypal are already starting to block people like
they brought,
mastercard was instrumental in blocking Spencer Roberts Benzer right.
It's Robert Spencer not retreated spans here.
Yes.
It's the best selling author.
And the guy who runs,
she had watched mastercard required patron two d plot form him.
And just to be very clear,
they sent out a tweet,
which everyone can find.
I'm shocked that they haven't deleted it yet where they said that they,
and they use this word,
which I think is the key to the whole thing.
They said that they unfortunately had to delete his patrion because of
mastercard.
So what are they actually saying?
There are these patriot and saying,
oh,
we didn't want to delete your page,
but mastercard forced our hand.
I mean,
that is some deeply scary stuff.
Yeah.
Well,
and we have to talk about hate speech because you know,
I think the whole concept of,
look,
obviously there is people can be very nasty when they communicate,
but the idea that there's an identifiable category and you can put boundaries
around it and it hate speech,
and then you can produce committees or deal with people on a one to one basis as
patron is doing without any central policy or let's,
despite their central policy or that you could turn that into an algorithm that
could validly identify hate speech without producing false positives,
right.
Without accusing people who shouldn't be accused of violating.
All of that is just completely,
it's just bakers,
the imagination as far as that.
Oh,
of course.
And you're also just opening a Pandora's box from hell because just in the last
couple of days,
I don't know if you saw this,
but the women's march in California canceled their rally because they felt that
it was too white.
Now imagine if they canceled their rally because it was too black or too
anything else.
It's like,
so is that now count as,
hey,
are you guys now being racist against white people?
Now we know that that wouldn't be a problem for these guys.
One of the things that I can't fathom in some senses the lack of imagination on
the part of the people who are engaging in censorship of what they regard as
hate speech.
Like there's an old military adage,
which is that if you intend to weapon it will be used by your enemy within 15
years.
Okay.
So why,
what makes the people on the,
on the left?
Because they're the ones who are doing this.
As you can clearly see in the,
uh,
change the terms website,
what makes them so sure that exactly the same tactics won't be used against
them.
Like at the drop of a hat once,
once the tactics have been validated and put in place.
I think it's either,
it's either just very short sightedness on their hand or they think that they
can actually stamp out enough hate within that very small window before it would
turn on them.
Or they just don't think these things fully through.
Yeah.
Or,
or there's another,
there's another possibility too,
which is that there are so opposed to the fundamental structures of the West
that let's say in regard to Ms,
so patriarchal,
oppressive,
that they'd be willing to take the risk of sacrificing their own free speech
just to have there what have their destructive way,
something like that.
We should also acknowledge that in the New York Times piece that was written,
which was written by Nellie Bowles,
who wrote the now infamous piece about you and enforcement alchemy,
that the quote that Jacqueline Hart,
who is the head of trust and safety over patrion.
Right,
good.
And there's no hidden who has no grounding in philosophy or any of the
background training that might be necessary to even remotely begin to
participate properly in such a thing.
No,
of course not.
But so the quote that she gave Nellie in the article said that you can't say
these what loosely quoting this now you can't say these words on our platform
referring to Carl,
referring to him saying the n word in that video,
which we,
which we know they were using out of context and all that.
But he never set it on their platform.
He never said it on Patrion and he didn't even say it on his own channel.
That was you,
you know,
using Patrion for the funding.
So there was a,
it's almost the entire story was built on quicksand that tried to put out there
on the New York Times.
Now,
of course myself and many other people tweet the hell out of it and gets
hundreds and thousands probably of and comments to Nellie and she doesn't
respond,
nor does the New York Times issue any sort of correction about the most
fundamental piece of the story was alive and they don't.
They don't have a problem doing that.
So that's why this is so layered about speech and finance.
And John was so amazing to see journalists take the journals.
One of the things that happened in Canada to me was that,
you know,
after I made the initial videos that caused such a political furor was that once
the main journalists in Canada sort of figured out what I was doing,
they all came out in my support.
Like the post media group,
which is 200 newspapers all came out to support what I was doing because they
realize that,
oh,
they're journalists.
Apart from Comedians,
there isn't anybody who relies more on the principle of free speech to justify
and allow their occupation even to exist for the New York Times.
Not Too understand that this threat is that also a threat to everything upon
which their entire organization has been predicated is also an indication of
that same kind of willful blindness that we've already been discussing.
But having said that,
I would still like to say that I think the biggest danger here I really,
and it's just made my jaw drop over the last couple of weeks thinking about it,
is the fact that the credit card companies are now taking it upon themselves to
potentially police the activities of their users.
He's like,
my God.
Is that really,
I just,
I just can't believe that we,
any sensible person would think that through and then want to live in a society
where your spending habits are being monitored by the company that basically
produces your money.
Think of anything more totalitarian than that.
So loosely quote our friend Eric Weinstein.
Should Republicans be allowed to use roads that,
that sort of where we're headed here,
that every public good will be eventually decided,
can you access to it?
Will you have access to water?
It should,
uh,
should an avowed white supremacist right now that is potentially watching this
or lives in America somewhere.
She's one of the 50 of the,
one of the 42 of them should,
should they have access to water at their home?
Should they allow it to be able to get electricity at their home or phone lines
or all of these things?
I mean,
this is where we're headed.
Especially when you ever expand the definition of who that person is.
Yeah.
They won't in China.
Right?
Well,
that's where they're going.
Right?
So is that the test case?
Well,
I think it's,
it's an indication that the fact that the Chinese have been tempted into this is
also an indication of the temptation.
It's intrinsic in the technological power.
The credit card companies are in a weird situation as far as I'm concerned,
because the only reason they work at all is because people actually trust them
completely,
right?
It's like,
oh,
you're just a proxy for money.
Like you're a proxy for cash.
In fact,
that's basically how the mastercard advertises itself,
right?
So you're a proxy for cash and the government doesn't watch what you spend your
money on except in extraordinary,
it's extraordinarily limited cases.
I mean,
there are money laundering laws and so forth,
but that's a direct violation of a law,
right?
That's part of tracking down criminal activity that has nothing to do so far
with,
with hate speech,
which by the way,
is protected by the first amendment.
So,
or which means in some sense that it doesn't exist,
you know,
as,
as illegal as illegal,
uh,
concept.
But this is my Canada,
which is,
we shouldn't go over that fact too because you know,
Jordan,
we just did however many countries in Europe and we're going to go back this
spring and it's like everybody that we met was jealous of the freedoms that we
have in the United States relative to speech.
You know what I mean?
Everybody that would come up to us after the show,
holy cow,
I wish we could say that and I wish we didn't worry about this or that or jokes
or the rest of it.
And we did that video in Oslo where you talked about Yankila and it's like
they're jealous of our freedom.
So we should be very clear here that though you're right,
because we now have a payment processor issue,
which is in indirect connection to whatever it is that we're trying to build out
here.
And we're still,
it's a little amorphous at the moment.
Um,
is that it's changing because a lot of people are saying,
all right,
you guys really want to solve this,
then you have to go full.
Crypto video has to be hosted crypto.
Yeah.
The finances have to be hosted or have to be done via critical.
All of these things,
these are,
these are major,
major things that we're trying to figure out on every front.
Certain payment processors are a little more willing to stand up to the mob than
others.
So we're talking to different people.
I mean we'll really go on on everything.
That's right.
Well,
the tentative platform that we're trying to build and to build carefully,
we'll provide the possibility of multiple payment portals in the hope that they
creators will be less susceptible to being rapidly shutdown or perhaps shutdown
at all.
But you know,
only a fool would say that that problem is going to be definitively solve.
I have some real increasing sympathy for the crypto currency types.
No,
but the problem there is that as far as I can tell,
their solution is still sufficiently technically complex to keep it out of the
mainstream use and also not sufficiently liquid to actually constitute a
realistic current replacement even for credit cards.
Right.
So one of the things we've been discussing is that it's almost like we have to
have several markers down the road to figure out what the real solution is
because not everything can be solved in terms of terms of service tomorrow
related to everyone that exists.
Not Everything can be solved tomorrow related to the payment processors may be
crypto really is the ultimate answer,
but it's not the answer tomorrow for everything.
So we're,
we're really,
we're plotting out a lot here,
but it seems like a fresh and sort of fitting way to start the year.
I think
so.
And so for January 15th I mean,
part of the reason that we picked that date,
as I said before,
it was because we thought we might have something to announce with regards to an
alternative platform,
but no saner heads have prevailed in that,
in that
calmer heads.
Yeah.
And also we wanted to give people an opportunity to decide what they wanted to
do without just springing it on them.
I mean,
I have some real admiration for Harris for acting so immediately and
definitively.
Yeah.
And it's funny,
you know,
I saw some criticism,
it's like,
all right,
well Sam dropped immediately and look you and Peter said you're still there and
you're talking about this whole thing.
And it's like we all have different things to consider.
We all have different family situations,
different business situations,
different livelihoods situations,
everything.
So it's like we were really trying to just plot this thing out properly and to
be very clear,
we're still in the process of that.
So for any,
so for anyone watching this right now,
if you're supporting Jordan on Patrion or you're supporting me on Patrion or
both of us or whatever it is,
it's like now we're trying to shift people
because@leastbygettingoffpatrionatthemomentweremoveoneofthemiddlemenandyoucannowgodirectlygotodirectlytojordanbpetersondotcomororgavereuben.com
and you can at least if you want to donate,
you can do that for now while we figure out everything else.
And that way we removed one of the pieces here because there's just too many
pieces here that,
that are creating this mess.
I think it's too much to hope for a perfect solution to a very complex problem.
And um,
we're muddling through the best we can and hopefully people will regard our
decision joint decision too.
Leave Patrion as a step in the right direction,
however imperfectly taken.
Yeah.
Well look,
I think I said it before,
but I really think that,
and maybe this will be the defining,
uh,
idea of 2019 is that I think we're basically at the point where people have to
decide what sort of internet they want.
And it's not only what sort of internet,
it's really what sort of freedom do you want in a digital world and either
aren't,
do you want any or do you want any,
and maybe maybe you don't or you don't want to think about it and you just want
to play fortnight and watch porn and never think it through
assuming that you'll be allowed to watch porn.
Right?
So that now you really are playing or played for that matter.
Right.
So the the games of violence should be allowed.
What makes you think that credit card companies should allow you to use their,
their funds to purchase first shoot,
first person shooter games for example,
or,
or any game where anyone is killed.
No,
you're totally right.
That's,
I mean that sounds completely dystopian and yet it seems like that would just be
the next encroachment that we would see here.
So the point at the end,
at the end of this is I think everyone for 2019 since it's the first day of the
year,
it's like you have to think about what type of Internet do you want,
what type of ability to communicate with other people do you want?
And if you want something that's a little better than what we've got right now,
we better stand up quick because this window,
we know it's closing slowly,
but we never know when it's going to really slap shot quick.
So,
so we're working on it and,
and I think people are ready to stand up with us.
I really do.
We might also suggest to people,
and this is of course up to everyone who's viewing this to decide,
but you know,
couple of thousand letters to mastercard and paypal and visa indicating
pronounced displeasure at their plans to become a custodians of the monetary
supply for ethical reasons might also be an order.
You know,
these companies are responsive to public pressure,
which is perhaps partly why they're determining to play the role of censor to
begin with.
You know,
there they are facing pressure from these,
let's call them activist interest groups who again are outlined on changed the
terms on the website,
change the terms and they're responding to public pressure and too,
so that's understandable.
MMM.
It's understandable,
but
yeah,
but inexcusable in certain in a certain regard,
but the right way perhaps to begin to push back is to let the credit card
companies know that there's a constituency on the other side that I s I suspect
constitutes the vast majority of credit card users.
The silent middle majority of let's say,
Western society who are neither radically right nor radically left,
who would just assume not have their spending habits monitored by giant
corporations.
It's funny too that the left is so opposed to corporate entities,
you know,
on principle,
especially to sizable ones and you know,
have a certain justification for being skeptical about the moral direction of
very large organizations,
um,
are so eager to hand over the reigns of social control to precisely the
companies you'd think they would be least likely to crawl into bed with.
I mean,
really mastercard visa.
It's like right.
Or at the same time though,
they want to hand over more control to the government to handle these things.
And we should be pretty clear that in the last couple of weeks that we've been
discussing this,
every single discussion that we've had about this,
I don't think once did we entertain the idea of,
Oh,
we've got to get the government involved to fix this thing.
I mean there,
there could be,
as you,
as you referenced earlier,
there could be specific legal,
uh,
issues that pop up related to collusion and signed a couple of other things.
Cartel develop car t yeah.
Like that sort of thing.
Yeah.
But the beauty of this,
and again,
why I'm so I'm,
I'm watching my,
my monthly rev of my company go down even though we're,
we're making some of it back,
but as I'm watching that happen,
as I said to you last time,
I'm,
I'm incredibly inspired right now because literally thousands of emails are
pouring in from people that want to work with us,
that want to help us,
that want to figure out how to fund things or that want to work as engineers in
the rest of it.
And that tells you that,
that people are,
people are afraid and they see this problem and they just want some solutions
and,
and maybe there isn't an easy solution.
As you said
there.
I've also been talking with you online with a whole bunch of the people who've
been loosely aggregated under the ages of the intellectual dark web.
And that's probably 30 people that,
that we've been communicating with,
with a variety of peripheral people.
And it's also useful to let people know that every one of those people is
unbelievably concerned about what happened to Carl Benjamin to start,
start,
go on.
And even more so
dumbstruck by the collusion of the payment processing companies and,
and the emergence of this activists infrastructure online that's devoted
specifically to the suppression of free speech.
Yeah.
So,
and also we should also note that within that group of say 30 or so,
my people,
we all sort of w look,
we agree on basic fundamental principles related to free speech and things like
that,
but there's a lot of disagreement on how to move forward with this.
I mean,
we're talking it out respectfully as we always do,
but some people are saying,
stay in fight on Patrion because this is how,
you know,
they're small enough say that you might get them to change.
Some people are saying you got to go when people are saying some version of,
you know,
mixing those
and nobody's clear about the proper pathway forward.
Yeah.
But that's again,
I mean I think this is what the brilliance of human ingenuity is all about.
It's like where they're going to be some pitfalls in front of us and staying
would have its risks and leaving would habits,
risks and we're all going to do what we think
we've already discussed that too,
right,
is that there's,
there's no,
there's no known risk option here and like and so we're taking the risk of
leaving and then we're going to make the best of it.
I mean often when you take a risk often in life,
all you have is a choice between two different risks and sometimes neither of
them are risks you would like to take.
Then in the aftermath of the decision,
a new field of possibility opens up in front of you too and whether or not you
made the right decision,
he's actually a consequence of how well you manage the aftermath of the
decision.
So we'll,
we'll keep talking over the next couple of months in on like I've got good
people working on this alternative,
you know,
which,
which was as I mentioned in other places,
started seven months ago or so.
And good people supervising it,
whether it'll turn out to be a viable product and whether or not we can figure
out how to implement it in a sustainable way that actually addresses these
issues in a reasonable manner remains to be seen.
Yeah.
On a,
on a personal note,
just because,
uh,
you know,
I got to see you a couple of days before Christmas in West Palm Beach and we had
dinner with that with your family and your kids and everything hasn't,
it's sorta been nice cause I did a week with uh,
with my brother and sister and nieces and nephews over Christmas.
Also sort of circling back to family on some of this.
It's given me a lot of perspective.
You know,
it it mean cause I'm getting,
I'm getting reached out by so many different people on all different fronts.
But then to have sort of a close knit group of people that really do have your
interests in mind and all those things
with your kids at dinner,
it was like,
oh these are good people to
well there's unanimity on the part of the people around me that the proper thing
to do is twofold.
One is to separate myself from patron in accordance with our discussions in the
second is to proceed with exceeding caution and not over promise,
um,
or try to deliver to quickly a solution.
Although to work on that carefully.
So that's what we've decided to do.
Yeah.
So let's just be crystal clear on that latter,
latter part.
We are working on this.
We're going to be deliberate.
We're going to be cautious.
We understand that it can't be solved tomorrow.
We understand that there's a financial part of free speech part and everything
else and we're just going to lay these things out in front of us and we're going
to keep working through it with a lot of the people that you guys know and trust
and,
and with,
with some other people.
And,
and hearing from random people that had given us ideas.
I mean I've been forwarding you emails left and right where people are like,
you know,
this might be the pet the pressure point you might want to go after.
So we're just going to keep going.
Yup,
Yup.
Okay.
Well I got a couple of things to end this.
I guess let's summarize it then.
I've got a couple of things just to let people know about.
Sure.
So,
um,
uh,
well the first is,
so we're both leaving on January 15th in a second is we're working on this
platform and the third is a warning to people to keep a close eye on what the
credit card companies are up to because that's a really bad thing in my
estimation.
I guess that's probably it on my front.
I have a talk coming up in Zurich.
I have a couple of talks in California in January.
I'll be with you on those.
Yup.
And the tickets to those are available on my website@jordanbpeterson.com and the
final thing is I also set up with my partners as a new year's,
uh,
token,
let's say that future authoring program from the self authoring suite.
And we put it up at 50% off with the code and why 2019.
And so if anybody's out there wants to make some personal,
what do you call those resolutions for the new year,
then this program is an ideal way of doing that.
And so that's also partly a thank you to everyone who,
um,
has been so supportive and interested in the last year.
And so I think that's basically,
I think that's basically that.
No,
I think that's basically it.
So I'll just quickly,
uh,
you know,
give a shout out to Dave rubin.com/donate and what we're,
what we're trying to do,
and I know you're trying to do this as well,
is that for whoever signs up now and we're,
we're taking,
it's one time,
monthly donations that you can do.
There are going to be ways that we think once we build out whatever it is we're
working on that uh,
that it'll all be able to be flipped into that.
So it's not like we're going to have people constantly having to start new
accounts or,
or you know,
sign up for new things or anything like that.
We're trying to make this as easy as possible for everybody and they'll look,
there's going to be some bumps,
but
yeah,
this is it.
That's one to say about 2019 there's going to bed.
There's going to be some bumps.
Well,
I don't know if you know this Jordan,
but we got an American election come and they year after that.
So
Mr Ruben,
happy new year.
All right,
happy new year,
brother.
I'll see you in a in Cali and a couple of weeks.
Bye for now.